Je t'admire presque
toujours dans ces
rues en courant, puis coupe, je suis juste
étonné que je n'arrive pas à
[Musique]
tes
paroles pour que tu ne puisses pas surveiller ton cul
là-bas, ok, tout ira bien, ils
m'aiment et
détective  Foley, tu as déjà lu tes
cinq fusillades qui ont souvent mis le feu aux poudres,
s'il te plaît, dis-moi que tu n'as pas
encore été arrêté deux fois, mais je me suis
évadé, nous avons mis nos vies en jeu tous les
jours et pour ce qui vient avec le travail si
vous le faites.  c'est
vrai ouais
[Musique]
[ __ ]
alors combien de personnes as-tu énervé
jusqu'à présent Je n'ai énervé personne ouais
5050 5050 est-ce si haut jusqu'à présent
[Musique]
wow
ça